today marks exactly six months since
Hurricane Maria slammed into Puerto Rico
the category four storm knocked out
power to the entire island at least 64
people were killed and after the storm
more than 135 thousand people were
reportedly left Puerto Rico for the US
mainland it is considered one of the
most logistical challenging natural
disasters in modern American history
today less than 10 percent of the island
is still without power and all 68
hospitals are open david beg no return
to one hard-hit area that's still
struggling to recover this is where
hurricane maria made landfall six months
ago java-- KOA on the southeastern part
of the island these days you'll get a
pretty good cell phone signal waters
running but people here haven't had
electricity since September Jamaa tease
a woman who fishes for a living and now
she's working to rebuild her home by
hand we had 35 hours on the ground to
see as much as possible and so we
reached out to locals on social media
and said what are the must-sees and the
response was overwhelming they said yeah
boo koa and the central part of the
island
on September 20th in Yabba koa 155
mile-per-hour winds brought hell in high
water sixty-five percent of people
living here still don't have electricity
that be met I would he got Mayor Rafael
surio says the first team to arrive to
restore power took 75 days 75 days
desperation has a relentless hold on
people here the mayor told us a few days
ago a local man took his life a man in
his 60s he lived at this blue house
right here apparently the same day he
was found hanging from a tree the same
day power was restored to his house 18
year old Denise pagan found the man he
was her neighbor didn't think the fact
that thing that somebody would take her
own life or something it really gets to
her she said she feels that she's too
young to see something that she's only
18 years old relief is coming largely
from volunteers like those from all
hearts and hands people wearing purple
replacing blue tarps with actual roofs
from Yaba KOA one of the thousands of
social media messages we received led us
to loss Piedras a woman reached out to
us on social media and said you've got
to see what conditions my bedridden
father has been living in for the last
six months the Santana sisters
introduced us to their 90 year old
father Guillermo when I shook his hand
he's he's hot he's warm to the touch the
day before we arrived someone brought a
solar panel system that allows them to
have the light we have in the room
allows them to operate this respiratory
machine more or less we're surviving but
it's not easy as we drove around the
island a majority of the traffic lights
that we saw were not working but overall
progress is being made within the last
few days the power generation here in
the island has hit 99 percent so we
wanted to talk to the US Army Corps of
Engineers which has the task of helping
to restore electricity on the island
the magnitude of destruction of this
power grid is beyond anything that we've
seen in America post storm 80%
destruction of the grid these poles
these lines accepted and using
helicopters we've brought more to the
island in the last month because you you
have to use helicopters in many cases to
attach and then pull the wires across a
given ballot a lot of people have said
to me are they making it better than it
was before the storm we're not burying
the lines because if we were doing that
we wouldn't have power back today to 92
percent of the populace burying it is
better safer stronger but it would take
a whole lot more time it would take a
whole lot more time and that may be a
future State future decisions see you
I'm glad you're well we first met Ponce
a police officer Daniel Pacheco last
October things have gotten a lot better
overall he says life is improving the
drops a sword have food they're stocked
you can actually go and get grocery in
don't have to do to our line but in the
mountainous middle region of the island
who to Otto is still in the dark
headlights guided our way to Esther
rosario's home she runs a generator at
night how are you doing no nothing good
it's hard without water she told us
she's housing her son daughter-in-law
and three grandchildren because their
home was destroyed during Hurricane
Maria that's the lion that's it
it has been our experience that Puerto
Ricans are some of the most resilient
Americans we've ever met after the storm
there was a rush to get things done in
order to save lives but now that rush
has shifted to getting those things done
before the next hurricane season begins
on June 1st
for CBS this morning I'm David Pegg no
in Yabba Cola Porto Rico thanks David
great June 1st just seems like tomorrow
I'm so glad that he's showing that story
again because even though they've made
progress you see they still have so much
work to do there and Porter we go such a
beautiful place that's right and man
that the next storm season coming just
barely get a determination of Puerto
Rican boy are you okay